here's just a funny little media story
it's becoming more and more popular in
some online circles to interject non
sequiturs about Jeffrey Epstein didn't
kill himself and the you're seeing this
on Fox News you're seeing this online in
the meme world I saw Joe Rogan tweeting
some funny memes related to it as well
and Fox News was taking a cue from
Donald Trump and doing a segment about
military dogs you might remember last
week Trump tweeted about the dog that
was apparently involved in the suicide
of Isis leader Abu Bakr al-baghdadi and
so total Fox clown Jesse Waters said hey
let me do a segment about patriotic
military dogs so we interviewed a former
Navy SEAL who knows about military dogs
and the Navy SEAL blurts out Epstein
didn't kill himself when the segment was
winding down and it actually looks for a
moment like Jesse Watters isn't even
really paying attention to the guests
there seems to be a delay that's longer
than the satellite delay that they seem
to be experiencing here is warrior
foundation warrior Dog Foundation
founder Mike Ritland taking a cue from
the Epstein didn't kill himself memes
and doing it on live TV whose to your
left there and I'm sure he's ready to go
out on the next mission and he can't
wait so thank you and thank Nero for
your service I appreciate it absolutely
if I could could I throw a PSA out real
quick real quick just the the remarkable
nature of these dogs and them being
highlighted in the news creates a huge
demand by people that frankly shouldn't
have them if if you see the the coverage
and you decide I want one of these dogs
either by a Finnish trained you know
fully trained and Finnish dog from a
professional now or just just don't get
one at all that and Epstein didn't kill
himself all right okay thank you for
that commentary all right Mike maybe
more on that later
and tonight this is starting to get a
cult following we dealt with some of the
facts last week I don't feel that it's
necessary to go back into it it does not
seem like this story is going to go away
anytime soon it's particularly popular
with the Fox News crowd but I want to be
really clear the Epstein stuff is not
just a right-wing can
Spira C theory at this point by any
means I'm in favor of inquiry I'm in
favor of investigation I want to figure
out what happened if we don't believe
the official story then we should demand
transparency about what took place but
what I want to mention to you today the
opportunity I want to take here is to
remind you that all of these
right-wingers who believe that Epstein
was killed not that he died by suicide
the right-wingers are missing the rest
of the story they're not closing the
circle Donald Trump was accused of
having raped a 13 year old girl at
Jeffery Epstein's Manhattan apartment
Trump is on video which we've played for
you with Epstein evaluating the
attractiveness of young ladies in a very
awkward looking situation if you do
believe that there was a plot to have
Jeffrey Epstein killed and to have it
ruled a suicide in order to prevent the
trial from going forward but you don't
believe any of the disturbing and
disgusting allegations that involve
Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein then
you're missing arguably the biggest part
of the story so I'm with you inquire
investigate seek the truth look at the
autopsy reports raise all the hell you
want but don't pretend that if indeed
there was a plot to silence Jeffrey
Epstein before a trial that it has
nothing to do with Donald Trump
potentially being incriminated by that
possible Epstein trial you're like 80%
of the way there
but you're ignoring the Trump piece
which is allegedly and potentially a
really major piece in the entire Jeffrey
Epstein Fiasco so there it is
funny moment on Fox News we will see if
this becomes a trend and more and more
people do it on corporate media